[Música]
economía en directo américa de france 24
y por supuesto tocamos todo lo que tiene
que ver el impacto económico de esta
guerra que se está librando en ucrania
jorge hurtado bienvenidos iniciamos un
viernes hablando de la posible salida de
rusia del sistema financiero swift
cuáles son las implicaciones así es y
bueno pese a que eeuu y la unión europea
en un principio habían descartado esta
opción como una sanción contra la acción
militar de rusia en ucrania ayer el
presidente estadounidense joe biden
volvió a revivir la opción pero antes es
importante aclarar a qué nos referimos
con el sistema swift la sociedad de
telecomunicaciones financieras
interbancarias mundial es conocida como
swift es una cooperativa de
instituciones financieras que fue creada
en 1973 la institución está supervisada
por el banco nacional de bélgica en
colaboración con otros grandes bancos
del mundo como por ejemplo la reserva
federal de eeuu el banco de inglaterra y
el banco central europeo no hay que
confundirlo con un banco swift es por
así decirlo un sistema de mensajería de
seguridad que conecta a más once mil
instituciones financieras de todo el
mundo en unos 200 países aproximadamente
una de sus funciones es alertar a los
bancos cuando se van a realizar
transacciones para darnos una idea el
sistema swift registró el año pasado una
media de 42 millones de mensajes al día
de esto rusia representó solamente el
1,5 por ciento de las transacciones esta
medida se ha planteado como una de las
más severas que se pueden tomar contra
la economía rusa y tendría un efecto
inmediato y a largo plazo lloré y le
pregunto entonces cuál sería el impacto
para rusia y europa y occidente logran
definitivamente sacar a rusia de ese
sistema bueno raúl básicamente esto los
dejaría fuera de la mayoría de las
transacciones bancarias a nivel
internacional de forma que no podrían
recibir los beneficios por ejemplo de la
producción de petróleo y gas que rusia
exporta y que representa para ellos más
del 40 por ciento de los ingresos de ese
país en 2014 se planteó esta idea y
rusia calculó que su producto interno
bruto caería un 5 por ciento de
aplicarse la sanción de sacarlo del
sistema swift entonces rusia decidió
establecer su propio sistema de
mensajería financiera a nivel doméstico
aunque actualmente sólo se usa en el 20%
de las transacciones internas en ese
entonces también rusia declaró que
sacarlo del sistema financiero swift
equivaldría a una declaración de guerra
eeuu ya logró sacar a un país de este
sistema fue irán por el programa nuclear
pero esta vez expulsar a rusia
perjudicaría a otras economías incluida
la de eeuu y un aliado clave como es
alemania eeuu requiere el apoyo de
europa para tomar una decisión de tal
magnitud pero europa había rechazado a
esta opción tomando en cuenta que rusia
es un proveedor de energía clave para
ellos el ministro francés de finanzas
bruno gelber aseguró que la opción de
escribir a rusia el sistema mundial de
pagos interbancarios swift seguía
abierta pero que sería un último recurso
escuchamos que dijo
primero atacaremos un cierto número de
sectores estratégicos atacaremos el
transporte atacaremos el sector de la
aeronáutica atacaremos el sector de los
semiconductores atacaremos todas las
tecnologías sensibles de la economía
rusa atacaremos el sistema financiero
ruso tools
vamos a atacar los bancos rusos
queremos aislar financieramente a rusia
queremos cortar todos los vínculos entre
rusia y el sistema financiero mundial
este es el último recurso swift pero es
una de las opciones que quedan sobre la
mesa perdiz is one de options for women
son the table jorge y nosotros seguimos
analizando con los expertos en economía
el impacto de esta escala en europa del
este así es y bueno antes tuvimos la
oportunidad de conversar con vicente
albornoz l decano de la facultad de
ciencias económicas y administrativas de
la universidad de las américas en
ecuador sobre la reacción mundial de los
precios de los commodities en este
conflicto las consecuencias también no
sólo para rusia sino también para europa
escuchamos que dijo donde están sobre
todo en materia de producción no es un
gran productor de productos industriales
por ejemplo
es un gran productor de computadoras de
microchips y celulares
el tipo de línea blanca como sería china
por ejemplo rusia es un gran proveedor
de materias primas
uno de esos petróleo y el otro
importantísimo gas y eso es lo que le
golpea a algo
jorge y por supuesto vamos a repasar
como amanecieron las bolsas los
indicadores bueno el rebote de los
mercados mundiales comenzó en nueva york
ayer y se extendió durante la jornada en
las bolsas asiáticas con inversores que
apostaron por los mercados de acciones y
divisas vinculados a las materias primas
el indice msc y de acciones de asia
pacifico subió alrededor de un 1 por
ciento tras caer 3,1 por ciento el día
anterior y en europa las principales
índices bursátiles europeos rebotaron
desde sus mínimos de 9 meses tras un
repunte tardío en wall street ya que los
inversores buscaban gangas después de
que las fuertes ventas de esta semana
fueron provocadas por la invasión de
rusia y ucrania jorge gracias entonces
por toda la información económica
pasamos ahora a ver en nuestro reportaje
del día
[Música]